what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so spawn is a really really cool
concept in the realm of comic books and
how we go as far as to say when it comes
to independent publishers basically you
know core concepts or or characters or
teams who were created by people outside
of Marvel and DC spawn is probably the
most popular like I really feel like he
is I mean back in the early 1990s you
had a lot of like really really popular
creations outside of Marvel and DC
namely you had image in valiant but I
say spawn is still probably the most
popular and the reason is because he's
had an exceedingly long ongoing series
been stretching on for a couple decades
now but he's pretty hardcore so why did
the clock back to the early 1990s you
had Jim Valentino you had Jim Lee you
had Tomic farlan you had a whole bunch
of people who basically broke away from
the main line coming with publishers and
the reason for this was that where Steve
Gerber did successfully a hunger feed I
don't think it successfully did where he
did sue Marvel Comics over the rights to
Howard the Duck what that did is he
created a creators Bill of Rights things
that like creators were basically
entitled to the problem with this was
that characters in concept had to
basically walk rank-and-file with like
what was expected of those characters
you know for example like Captain
America couldn't just become a villain
all of a sudden like you saw in secret
empire that had to be built up to or
something had to be done
but it's certainly not something they
would have done back in the 1990s and so
where people will kind of like live in
that era of comics and not really step
into the modern day and just kind of say
like that's the way things should always
be the fact remains that what you had is
you had a handful of creators who quit
they basically walked away and said
we're tired of writing somebody else's
characters we want to create our own
characters thus we got Image Comics and
Image Comics is a publishing house much
in the same way as Marvel and DC the
difference is that where Marvel and DC
have a shared universe meaning that in
Marvel Comics the Avengers will
crossover with the x-men and DC Comics
the Justice League will crossover with a
Teen Titans and Image Comics you don't
really have that image is just like a
giant publishing house for all kinds of
just creator own work you've got
Jonathan Hickman's east of West you've
got Todd McFarlane spawn and the idea of
spawn was to take the kind of superhero
archetype that existed at the time and
someone modify it adjust it and then
throw it back at the reader so if I were
a betting man I would say that spawn is
it's kind of like a hodgepodge of a
bunch of different characters he's one
part Batman one part Punisher I mean
he's got all these different things sort
of wrapped into into a cool bow and the
way this really picks up the way this
really shows itself is when this story
starts by an
when it comes to character origin
stories and comic books you usually get
the origin story almost right off the
bat within the first six issues or at
least the character like a set of events
unfold and the character becomes a
superhero or becomes a supervillain in
the spawn series spawn doesn't know how
he got there he doesn't really remember
anything all we know is that there's
like a five-year gap between the time he
basically died and the time that he woke
up he gets these small little flashes
here in there these small little faces
he sees himself involved in various
conflicts overseas different things like
that but that's about it but the one
thing that sticks in his mind is this
beautiful woman that he can't quite
figure I doesn't really know who she is
and that's one of the big differences
here is it spawn picks up basically
putting pieces of his life together and
not really understanding how he got
where he was but the funny thing about
this too is that it's basically our
ability to follow the story of spawn as
he learns who he is as a really as an
antihero more than anything else but
it's kind of cool here because what you
end up doing really the first big thing
that he does is he immediately leaps
into action now this is kind of like
todd mcfarlane playing on the nature of
superheroes right I mean we're not
really given a whole lot of expose into
like the character of spawn we just kind
of know he's there and he's a person who
can presumably do things and so it's one
of those situations where the actions of
his character are designed to tell us
who he is as opposed to him giving us
this huge explanation now the other
thing to bear in mind here is that this
is very reminiscent of late 80s and
early 90s colleagues a lot of the
characters that you're really really
familiar with encounter books Batman
Superman Wonder Woman all those
characters are you familiar with they've
been they've been around since the 1960s
or earlier going all the way back to
like the late 30s early 40s into the 50s
and so on and so forth and so because of
the fact that the nature of storytelling
in comics between the introduction of
Superman running all the way up until
about the the late 1970s kind of
followed the pattern of saying okay I'm
a superhero Here I am and here's what I
do here's how I gain my abilities if I
have any that kind of went away and
instead when you had like Rob Liefeld
method of storytelling which really goes
all the way back to like the latter days
of New Mutants going into the launch of
x-force it was kind of like just on the
scene we know that with characters like
cable cable was just there one day there
was no real explanation of where he came
from how he got there we didn't get that
into the x-force series started and even
then it was lightly teased and x-force
issue number six or whatever was and
then we got an actual explanation and
cables solo series so it took a little
while for us actually get that
information together and that translates
into this but the
nature of spawn comes into sharp relief
in the sense but he immediately jumps in
and stops a handful of guys from
basically like attacking a young woman
basically you know trying to victimize
her more or less now of course he makes
quick work of these guys but notice the
kind of things that he says he's
basically like look you guys clearly
picked the wrong one you know like I'm
here to stop you guys that kind of a
thing but then suddenly he gets a
flashback to like his own funeral you
know like a military-style funeral it's
really Todd McFarlane taking this whole
idea of spawn and taking like the Rob
Liefeld method of storytelling for
example ruling it over into this whole
thing and saying now here's little
tidbits here and there about like how
this whole concept came into existence
where the idea is it spawn is still
literally trying to figure himself out
now another way that this is shown here
is when he basically starts to remove
his garb and ends up finding out that
his flesh is almost totally destroyed so
again he's still figuring these things
out now at this point we actually jumped
to this sort of demonic entity this
guy's name is basically mal Borgia ah
that's really who he is now the role he
plays in at the beginning of the spawn
series it's the tip of the iceberg with
regards to like the grander scheme of
everything that's going on that's one of
the reasons why spawn is lasted for so
long is because it's very much like this
massive world building epic you know
that deals with angels and demons and
different things like that and so from
here we basically pick up with the
introduction of the violator now to be
honest to kind of you know inject my
opinion in here I love violator I think
violators hilarious and that's the way
he was designed to be the spawn comics
in and of themselves
were designed to be some pretty dark
comics and so when it comes to the
violator he's one part dark humor and
then one part just like sadistic and
screwed up and this is because he really
kind of opens up with him rambling on
about all the different ways to like
kill a person you know to basically take
out spawn different things like that to
like rip his spine out through his head
and and so on and so forth there's
really kind of being screwed up in and
sadistic but at the same time for Swan
himself it really is just going through
and trying to understand himself now
that's kind of one of the downsides
about the early spawn stories Todd
McFarlane's spent a lot of time with
spawn just sort of like thinking about
who he is and trying to figure himself
out I want to see I wouldn't go as far
as to say this is like a necessity to
have all this stuff but it's really just
one of these things where he kind of
reflects on the world around him because
he really is like a guy who sort of
wakes up with no real identity you know
amnesia almost and so again switching
back to the to the violator we basically
joined jawed joined on corporal we
basically have this this mob boss more
or less and the violator is going
through and killing each of these guys
but notice this he's actually ripping
their
hearts out in the process which is
pretty pretty screwed up like it's it's
pretty messed up seeing it all unfold
but this is when we start to learn
things about the kind of powers at spawn
has one of these is to take on the form
of another person now the implication or
I guess the indication here is that
because he doesn't really have a strong
understanding of his abilities it
happens outside of his desire meaning
it's almost like an impulse a
subconscious kind of mechanism that
kicks in that he can't necessarily
control it creates a bit of mystery and
it creates a bit of intrigue spawn is
learning about his powers and we're
learning about them at the same time
Metheny oh wow all this is taking place
we suddenly start to get a little more
information here and we basically pick
up with a guy by the name of Jason Wynn
this is kind of cool because again this
feeds into traditional comic book
landscapes or you've got the
arch-nemesis is really how this whole
thing unfolds now what we're told here
is that with Jason Wynn he was basically
the mentor of spawn the mentor of Al
Simmons essentially but he had taken Al
Simmons under his wing and he had turned
him into into really a prodigious
assassin and what this did is it
basically led to this revelation on
behalf of how Simmons that is time began
to progress that really Jason Wynn took
enjoyment and essentially like bringing
harm to others it wasn't enough to just
like execute these black ops campaigns
at the request of the federal government
he had to go a step further really carry
out these missions but do it in a way
where he was more vindictive than he
needed to be and as time began to
progress Jason Wynn began to enjoy
inflicting pain on others and so because
of this at some point along the line and
the way things seem to be indicated here
is that Al Simmons intended to like turn
on Jason Wynn to basically turn him in
reveal the things that he'd done so he'd
be put on trial for you know various war
crimes so on and so forth and the idea
seems to be that Al Simmons was taken
out as a result of his intentions here
and so again as time goes on we'll begin
to figure out more and more we'll see
more and more about the origin of Al
himself and so we're spawn kind of has
this interesting situation where he kind
of collapses just being overwhelmed by
the various memories that are
occasionally flooding back into his mind
he's met by a by the violator Robert and
this is kind of cool because while the
violator does look pretty screwed up in
juxtaposition to spawn he looks pretty
harmless he doesn't look like he can do
a whole lot he looks like a crazy clown
with face paint but the funny thing here
is that we also get little bits of
comedy you know this is it like he
basically
relieves himself more or less now I'm
gonna say to this day to one of the like
probably d12 really the only depiction
of the violator we ever got in film was
John Leguizamo but he
amazeballs oh my god like if you guys
never saw the spawn movie like John
Leguizamo was the highlight of that
movie he was hilarious but again the
violator just kind of has it out for
spawn the intention to basically kill
him and eliminate him in his entirety
we're not told why violator has it out
respond we just know that he does and so
again like from this point you pick up
with Mal Bhoja himself as actual demon
and now Bhoja begins to kind of fill us
in on a few things and what we end up
finding out here is that within the
confines of this story at least here in
the early days mal Bhoja is basically
the ruler of hell or at least that seems
to be the case now again this is Todd
McFarlane drawing on his time in Marvel
Comics because of those people who have
been reading spawn for any real measure
of time now bhauja bears a striking
similarity to Mephisto they look
completely different we're not really
completely different but they look very
different from one another but the roles
seem relatively similar now the
motivation behind mal Bhoja is really
what differentiates him from Mephisto
but the point still remains the same and
Marvel Comics Mephisto is a being who
rules over a dimension of hell Mephisto
takes the souls of those he tricks and
so that's why I like he took the soul of
dr. Doom's mom for example with mal
Bhoja it's much the same way the
difference here is that mal Bhoja really
seems to indicate that like spawn is
gonna serve a particular purpose have
spawn is here for a very particular
reason and the reason really seems to be
that one spawn basically handed his soul
over to mal Bhoja and two he didn't read
the fine print he didn't know what was
entailed in handing his soul over and
presumably allowing him to return to
Earth now again this is small little
tidbits being thrown in here small
little things here and there not a lot
of information is being given by Todd
McFarlane it's just kind of giving us
these small little tidbits and allowing
us to try to use our imagination to fill
in the pieces but from here spawn takes
the most logical step in his character
and again it's kind of a way for it fall
and they kind of give us this this sort
up tour of like the spawn mythos in this
sense that al basically Don's the
physical appearance of the blond guy
he's basically been mimicking from time
to time and goes back to his own home
only to basically find Wanda there now
the cool thing about this is that Wanda
looks just as beautiful as he ever
remembers well basically coming back
home and visiting his wife it's really a
not so much a desire to like rekindle
things so much as it is to figure out
what's going on with her and to
understand where she is at the moment
the sad thing about this is that Winnie
basically gets to his home he finds out
that his former wife has a daughter and
this was kind of crushing to him because
it's the one thing he could never give
her now the indication seems to be the
reason why he was
were able to give it to her is because
his job just required too much his job
required too much time away he wasn't
able to pay as much attention to his
wife as he should have and the result
was that when he began to realize how
important she truly was she was already
gone not only that we actually end up
finding out that she married a guy named
Terry and Terry was basically the former
partner of Al Simmons and the two of
them had basically grown closer through
the death of Alan so it makes sense that
as time progressed the two of them ended
up getting together and so this is kind
of an interesting scenario here because
it's one of those things where the way
it's done by Todd McFarlane al basically
has to let go like he has to move on he
can't be with his wife but to see her
happy is more important than being happy
with her and so that's the the cool
thing about this is that he ultimately
just kind of walks away now the sad
thing is that he's basically dealing
with the idea that like some unseen
force out there whom he doesn't really
seem to know much about seems to be like
kind of toying with his life and
basically putting him in a situation
where everything that's been valuable to
him has been taken away and so in this
moment of vulnerability he's suddenly
met by the arrival of the violator now
of course a violator does to him where
the violators been doing to a lot of
other people and rips out the heart of
Spawn but this again
goes into the nature of spawns powers in
the sense that when he's basically left
dead he kind of jumps back up again
begins to heal in the revelation here is
that he doesn't actually need a heart
and so the idea seems to be this spawn
is technically immortal he cannot really
be killed by conventional means now it
kind of brings in this whole thing of
well what does he have to lose here from
here like spawn and violator actually
get into a pretty cool fight now
violator is actually a little shocked
because in his mind he's kind of like
how do you not die like you're a human
how could you possibly live without a
heart and so it's kind of funny because
violator doesn't quite know how to
handle this situation of course spawn
takes his heart puts it back into his
chest and that's really the end of that
but the way that he talks is he
immediately sees violator as an enemy
and this again is a way for McFarlane to
kind of set things up and say that once
the whole situation with Jason Wynn is
sorted out the violator will go on to be
the main enemy of spawn that's the
indication that's given in this whole
story here and so well the two of them
do get into a pre knock-down drag-out
fight ah that really like sees violator
you know like a hole blown into him and
like his arm ripped off and different
things like that ultimately a you know
having mal Bhoja who simply just pops up
here and this is when we start to get
the explanation of what's going on this
is when we start to learn everything
that's happening mal Bhoja essentially
pops up and says both of you are on the
same side your servants for me you just
don't know
yes but the funny thing about this is
that malabo sure goes on to explain that
basically it's this ruler of health and
its goal is to destroy God but the
reason why spawn is here is because
spawn is designed to basically increase
the army of Mao Bojan to essentially
like punish those who are evil and
wicked or what have you and send their
souls to hell that's the point that he
that that he serves here and the reason
why is because Mao Bhoja intends to
build an army that's large enough to
challenge and conquer God and then bring
it into like his whole reign and that's
the whole basis behind why spawn is here
now if anything about this and this is
where the antihero element begins to
come into play is that Malvo just says
look the way this works is that the more
you use your powers for the closer you
come to like a second death basically
meaning if you go nuts with all your
powers if he does use your powers for an
extreme purpose then you'll basically
start decreasing your life at a faster
rate and your soul will belong to me or
you can use your powers slower and then
eventually I'll get your soul anyway but
you won't be able to plan out to punish
the wicked and so the idea is that no
matter what happens mal Bossier will get
the soul of spawn the funny thing about
this too is that mal Bhoja actually says
here that in this particular
circumstance and really in any
particular circumstance around the world
that when it comes to individuals whose
souls are harnessed by mal Bhoja he
can't just steal them Al Simmons had to
offer his soul so in a sense Al Simmons
sold his soul to the devil for whatever
it is the end goal was and so because of
that that's how now Bhoja was able to
steal steal the whole basis behind him
now the whole concept here seems to be
and really to provide a bit of a spoiler
here for future stories the way this
basically unfolded is it Swann sold his
soul to malabo juh under the idea that
he would basically be allowed to
quote-unquote return to earth and the
whole basis was to gain revenge but he
would serve as like the hell spawn but
when he showed back up here his mirror
was it was essentially wiped with the
exception of a small few tidbits here
and there and so what this meant was
that Al Simmons went forward as the hell
spawn and really kind of gets us to the
moment where he's trying to figure
himself out but that's the whole point
here is that when it comes to the
violator he seemed to be more of someone
who kept the kept spawn in check or at
least keeps him on the path he's
supposed to serve but that's where the
antihero element comes in is because as
we know spawn will go on to basically
defy Malvo Gaea and every opportunity he
gets to serve his purpose of like
punishing the wicked but really like
pushing them more on the path of doing
the right thing as opposed to like
expanding the army of mal bugs and
although betimes were unavoidable but
that's kind of the role that he serves
at this moment in time and so the result
here is the
way this this really kind of begins to
come to an end is that it's basically
spawn and it's in its violator on two
opposite sides they they serve the same
purpose but they're none too friendly
with each other they're not analyzed and
so what you have is you know just spawn
kind of going about and doing his thing
basically going forward into the next
few stories uh we begin to expand on his
character a little bit more learn a
little bit more about his past and all
that kind of good stuff but without
being said guys we're gonna go ahead and
ring this video to an end if you are new
here to come this explain it make sure
you guys have the sub button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you